KRISTEN: A FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE HAVE JUST LEARNED THAT
SENATOR RAND PAUL HAS TESTED
POSITIVE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
THE OFFICIAL CONFIRMATION CAME
IN A SERIES OF TWEETS JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
I WANT TO READ THEM TO YOU IN
FULL.
THEY READ: SENATOR RAND PAUL HAS
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVID-19.
HE IS FEELING FINE AND HE IS IN
QUARANTINE.
HE IS ASYMPTOMATIC AND WAS
TESTED OUT OF AN ABUNDANCE OF
CAUTION, DUE TO HIS EXTENSIVE
TRAVEL AND EVENTS.
HE WAS NOT AWARE OF ANY DIRECT
CONTACT WITH ANY INFECTED
PERSON.
HE EXPECTS TO BE BACK IN THE
SENATE AFTER HIS QUARANTINE
PERIOD ENDS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK FOR THE PEOPLE OF KENTUCKY
AT THIS DIFFICULT TIME.
TEN DAYS AGO OUR D.C. OFFICE
BEGAN OPERATING REMOTELY.
VIRTUALLY NO STAFF HAS HAD
CONTACT WITH SENATOR RAND PAUL.
THAT’S CERTAINLY SOME GOOD NEWS
THERE.
SENATOR RAND PAUL BECOMING THE
LATEST MEMBER OF CONGRESS TO
TEST POSITIVE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WE KNEW THAT THIS WAS CERTAINLY
A POSSIBILITY, WHEN YOU HAVE
THIS MANY MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
TRAVELING AND FLYING FROM ALL
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY TO CAPITOL
HILL.
LELAND: BRINGS UP A COUPLE
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
NUMBER ONE, VOTING, BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO VOTE IN PERSON, BY LAW,
ON THINGS, AND YOU’VE GOT THIS
HUGE COUPLE TRILLION DOLLARS
SPENDING BILL COMING UP.
THERE’S QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
HOUSE IS GOING TO DO.
WOULD THEY PASS IT BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT SO THEY DON’T ALL HAVE
TO FLY BACK FROM THEIR
DISTRICTS?
WHAT HAPPENS IF IT’S A CLOSE
VOTE?
WHAT ARE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RULES AS IT RELATES TO VOTING
FROM SOME DISTANCE AWAY?
THE OTHER THING ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL YOU THINK ABOUT RAND PAUL,
HE’S A PHYSICIAN HIMSELF.
IF THERE’S ANYBODY WHO WOULD
KNOW AS YOUR FATHER WOULD AND
OTHER DOCTORS THAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THE RISKS OF THE CORONAVIRUS AND
HOW TO BE CAREFUL IN YOUR EVERY
DAY LIFE NOT TO GET IT, IT WOULD
BE HIM.
IT DOES SHOW YOU HOW CONTAGIOUS
THIS VIRUS CAN BE.
WE KNOW CORY GARDNER IS IN
QUARANTINE AS WELL, THE SENATOR
FROM COLORADO.
IS THIS MUSHROOMED OUT AS WE
THINK ABOUT JUST HOW DIFFERENT
THE WEEK LOOKED A WEEK AGO, AND
WHAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT LAST
SUNDAY VERSUS TODAY, JUST
EXTRAPOLATE THAT OUT TILL SEVEN
DAYS FROM NOW AND AMERICA WILL
ONCE AGAIN LOOK VERY DIFFERENT.
KRISTEN: IT JUST SHOWS YOU
ANYBODY CAN GET THE CORONAVIRUS.
IF YOU THINK IT MIGHT BE EASY TO
ALLOW MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO
VOTE REMOTELY, JUST THINK OF
WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE IOWA
CAUCUS.
THESE THINGS ARE NOT EASY TO DO.
THEY’RE VERY TECHNOLOGICALLY
DIFFICULT.
WHILE THEY ARE NOT, YOU KNOW,
KIND OF LIKE COMPARING APPLES
AND ORANGES, BUT IT IS -- ANY
TIME YOU TRY TO DO SOMETHING
DIGITAL, THAT THAT IS THAT
COMPLEX, IT IS TOUGH.
LELAND: WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CONTINGENCY PLANS OUT THERE.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY GET PUT INTO
USE OR NOT, WE’LL WAIT AND SEE,
AS THE NEGOTIATIONS ON CAPITOL
HILL CONTINUE, AND THAT BILL
WAS -- THE SPENDING BILL WAS